Keamy go Bobby that's it he wa itsumo to
onaji
[Music]
mother they're a sheep mo mata gonna
machi there oh I didn't know that that
is one of Muriel's favorite songs from
Full Metal Alchemist oh really
yeah it was I don't remember it was a
outro or some [ __ ] like that but she
played it so much I actually memorized
the first verse I have no idea what that
whole [ __ ] means but I memorized it to
the point where I could sing it again
one more time
Amiga baby Natsu he wha itsumo to onaji
Jonny
so today we have the blue-haired the
illustrious blue rotten apple
the ching-chong princess doing a ching
chong chow
yay wow I didn't actually expect to like
start so soon yeah well you know we're
just getting people in here and this is
gonna be a very interesting podcast you
did youdid Barton Geo's podcast right I
did but Bart wasn't there because he was
too busy oh it was just you yeah it's
just me and you oh what the [ __ ] well
what'd they ask you because I don't want
to ask the same [ __ ] question I think
a lot of things like like how I've been
doing my goals of oh the goals I
achieved in 2018 and then they were
trying to get information about me and
my boyfriend's love story but I can't
say here either cuz my boyfriend has
something in Lund that he wants to do so
he wants to have [ __ ] your guys's love
story don't [ __ ] who the [ __ ] cares
about that a lot of people do David talk
about that love dude did you did you see
the post of a picture of us in high
school and then a picture of us recently
oh that's what you guys you guys with
the high school together yeah yeah so
like I think um it was something that my
boyfriend well you guys knew each other
since what freshman year no well he says
elementary school but I don't remember
anything of that I was [ __ ] funny
he's like you know what I've been in
love with you since the [ __ ] first
grade you're like who are you yeah and
then I remembered him in middle school
because I thought he was really annoying
but look at that guy's persistence is
key he only had to wait like 29 years
and then Wow
that's us freshman in high school and
then that's I think 20 that's so [ __ ]
wild yeah right dude Julia look at you
why are you so [ __ ] dark because I
was a cross-country run and I need ya
Ravi you look Mesquite as [ __ ] yeah what
is going on with his hair
I don't give a [ __ ] how hot Adam it was
my god dude it looks like he got into a
fight with the weed whacker and lost
dude all right in this photo I don't
think it does justice yeah in person who
woulda been worse for sure disgust I
knew a lot of people with that here I'm
not saying I was any better yeah we all
look like trash back in the day that's
not that's not just like his thing
everybody had like that weird hair and
when I was in junior high I remember
everybody was doing the the blonde hair
the [ __ ] tall spikes people used to
have like eight inch spikes to their
hair when I was a kid what I did was I
used to shave my head and I used to keep
the bangs in the [ __ ] [ __ ]
vietname gangbanger Sun and it would be
bleached it - yeah did you want to try
to like spike it up yeah like we used to
do some [ __ ] I'm not sure if y'all
remember this but there's something
everybody used to get under cuts so you
will grow out your hair and then you
will shave it all the way like the first
like layer close to your skin and it
would be undercut so if you lifted it up
you'd be shaved yeah and that was like
the hot [ __ ] to do the spiky hair the
ice tips is [ __ ] we look so [ __ ] dumb
our parents called a stupid and they
were right they were right from the jump
he looks so stupid dude I remember I
died or I bleached my hair to like a
sandy brown yeah so I just look like a
[ __ ] like fat lesbian oh oh so
[ __ ] cute dude I thought I was so
cute my [ __ ] I think the one look I
didn't I don't miss from the 90s is that
wet look like that hard gel look Oh
everybody had the what was it the la la
looks I don't know so everybody used to
get this gel called la looks I'm not
sure if that company still around they
probably are but that [ __ ] was thick as
uh and then every that's how they would
spike their hair so they would take the
LA looks and they would they would do
the individual spikes they would blow
dry that [ __ ] and then hairspray so it
was so funny because dudes you know just
because like masculinity I think back in
the day was it was just all about you
know like guys don't do [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that but it was so funny because
they would make fun of girls for taking
their time but if you saw a Vietnamese
dude with a hair like spiked hair you
how long it took him to get his [ __ ]
hair ready like my friends they would
every time we would try to go out
someone's like Oh what are we gonna go
out and you look at our to do my hair
but how dare you make fun of other
people for that [ __ ] dude you take an
hour to do your spikes you little [ __ ]
oh God wow I don't think I've spent a
lot of time on my hair until maybe
sometime after college like like you
just didn't wear any makeup at all
during no makeup in high school and then
even in the beginning of college I
didn't really wear any I just started to
really I started to practice with it in
my last year of college cuz then I
figured that I should start wearing
makeup for work really you're a super
late bloomer was it because your parents
were against her you didn't care I just
think I just didn't care I was too lazy
and I was just like man no way am I
gonna wake up 10 20 minutes early just
to get ready when I can just get ready
in five minutes
hmm that's precious sleeping time so do
you like doing makeup now like it's fun
yeah it's fun it's like painting yeah
makeup is [ __ ] hard too by the way it
is hard this is one of the hardest
things I've ever tried doing but like I
don't know I think recently I've been
buying a lot of makeup that I don't need
but that's I feel like that's what all
girls do right but you guys have an
equivalent of that whatever hobby that
they're in but it's like you get one
thing and then it's it's good for now
but then you want to try something new
try something new and then you go back
and you're like maybe maybe it'll go
well with this and you try it again and
you like it but there might be something
better out there because I feel like a
lot of girls do that with like lashes
right so they find lashes that they like
yeah and then there's something they
don't like about so they tried different
lash in another lash but a lot of people
have been doing whatever what do you
call those those lasting lash extensions
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah I'm just scared to do that but I
know people around us have done them
before
well we so scared about I don't know
just cuz like they sew it on or
something right or is it glue did it I
actually don't know anything about lash
that's like something new [ __ ] dude so I
don't know like my knowledge of like
cosmetics is just it's like from like 10
years ago when I used to work at the
beauty supply store so I don't know
anything new so I'm not quite sure if
it's something that they like so on or
like they leave on or if it's a
glue that like stays there but I don't
know the idea that just kind of really
scared cuz Gina does it it looks great
yeah yeah looks amazing on her is same
with Christina she does that too oh yeah
they also did the micro bleeding yeah
that's a new thing too it's so
interesting because like micro bleeding
sounds like hairs being sewn in but it's
literally tattooing yeah it's just it's
gashes and then within those gashes they
put an ink to fill out whatever so those
gashes look like strands of hair and
it's supposed to I'm not sure doesn't
that [ __ ] hurt I from what I was told
it doesn't hurt very much ah but I know
that like micro voiding is more of like
the fine-tuned of like tattoo brows cuz
I've seen people with tattoo brows and
they're like really thick and it's just
uh it's either thin but it's very bold
line yeah they don't have like eyebrow
hairs but with micro bleeding it just
seems so natural because it's like
feathery and it does every stroke of
your hair yeah and is supposed to work
with the hair that you already have so
it just kind of fills in those gaps
before I heard it it doesn't hurt I
think they numb you and then I think
it's just it feels like it's gross which
I'm not too sure I I'm too scared to do
those things there's so much maintenance
in being a girl like it's so unreal and
like I was talking about this recently
too and I don't know how like I feel it
this is like one of those things that
I'm always a little bit weird about
because you know I feel when I when I'm
on Twitter and I'm on like social social
media there has been this huge push so
the original push and the original idea
that people had when it came to beauty
was that you know I felt a lot of people
were telling like girls or young guys or
whatever that you should be happy with
the way that you are and if there are
things that you want to change you can
and just you know just learn to love
yourself and now it's like well the the
the opposite of that now is and this is
it seems to be the more popular thing is
well if you have the money to do it why
don't you just change your face Wow you
know like fillers like how many [ __ ]
girls do we know that they use fillers
on their face like they're just not
happy with the way that they look they
they want to go baby put like the
fillers in their lips here and there
and I don't know why I don't know how to
feel about that because on one hand what
they're saying is that you have one life
to live and if it makes you happy why
not do it because it doesn't affect
other people right like you're just
doing it to yourself so why should you
care so much a hundred percent like I do
agree with that
but the other side of it is when does it
when does it end like you're gonna age
like think these things are gonna happen
to your face right
and for me how I see it is that you're
really trying to fix a problem that's
never going to be fixed because you fix
one thing you're gonna want to fix it
again you're gonna want to fix it again
and if you're just never going to be
satisfied and I know it seems like a
blanket statement that I'm saying but
I've seen it happen so often or they
change one thing and they go oh I love
it it's perfect and then they they aged
like four or five years the base starts
to droop and like nope I got to put some
Botox here okay cool then they start
[ __ ] with their notes like everything
starts to change constantly
and then the issue that I have once
again is that when's that stop so
instead of like teaching the idea that
you are beautiful you know this is who
you are and there are people who are
gonna love you for what you look like
and who you are as a person you know why
do we always have to look at outside
factors for somebody to change what we
were already born with that's completely
fine there's nothing wrong with the way
that you look and a lot of the times the
a lot of these like social media girls
who I think are [ __ ] venomous snakes
because they're trying to put out this
book no they are because they're trying
to put out this movement right oh like
girls do you you know you're [ __ ]
beautiful the way you are but you got
seven lip injections you got [ __ ]
fillers all over your face and you got a
fake ass so what the [ __ ] are you
talking about you clearly didn't love
yourself enough to keep yourself the way
that you are right so I don't know I
mean I don't know what your thoughts
aren't as a girl that's how I see
there's a guy see I see so here's the
thing like I feel like I'm very
conflicted with it because yeah me too a
part of me feels like I've been
fortunate with nice genes in a way
because a lot of people tell me that I'm
pretty right even though there are days
where I don't feel like I'm pretty or
like there's things about me where I
don't think I'm pretty but a lot of
people say that I was like oh you're
pretty you have nothing to worry about
so then like listen I feel like I'm
classified into this area where
I somewhat don't identify with right
yeah and um it's it's kind of hard for
me to say and have much of an opinion on
it because I just feel like it's
difficult because whatever I say it's
gonna be taken the wrong way or it's
just like well you're fortunate because
you look the way you look and I'm just
like okay sure and you know arguably too
though the people that I know that are
that that want to do these changes and I
don't know them on a personal level
right but this is just girls that I've
seen online yeah and I see their before
and after I'm like you were beautiful
before the what the [ __ ] was the
difference right you know yeah so it's
like it's it's not even the girls that
from what I've seen that obvi like maybe
like cosmic like on the outside they're
just not as pretty yeah like I feel like
they cope with it and deal with it more
it's just there's a lot of women who
predicate their identity on what they
look like rather than who they are right
right and this goes for a lot of guys
too because I'm now I'm seeing guys that
are trying to do the cold cosmetic
surgery thing too so it just if you
predicate everything on this is what I
look like and this is how people will
perceive me and people say this [ __ ]
too which is which kind of annoys me
it's like well I'm just doing it for my
[ __ ] self well if you're doing it for
your [ __ ] self then why is it that
you're putting up ten thousand selfies
showing everybody else and then you
you're looking for those likes so
there's a little dishonesty about that
yeah you did do it for yourself to a
certain extent but it's not just for you
yeah so somebody else can tell you that
you're beautiful because you're used to
those compliments and you want to keep
receiving those compliments about your
looks because that's what you based your
whole [ __ ] life on you know and so
when I see that I'm just kind of like
it's it's always the people who I feel I
sometimes it's just you're perfectly
fine the way that you are and you're
just being hypercritical about the way
that you look because you base your
value on this exterior thing that's
gonna change anyways every we're all
gonna die we're all gonna [ __ ] look
like [ __ ] every asian person is gonna
end up looking like a turtle yeah like
I'm gonna look like a turtle you're
going to look like a turtle I feel like
I feel like one of the reasons why
people want to make themselves look
better not really just to satisfy like
what their personal insecurities are but
I think it's just fulfilling that I
guess
that notion or that thought where you
get away when you're pretty like you can
get away with a lot of things when
you're pretty and which is true and life
is a lot easier when you're pretty and
yeah yeah so it's just like with that
kind of notion of what that kind of
thought in mind it's like okay well why
not make myself pretty because I feel
like no live a easier life that way yeah
I mean it's just you know the grass is
always greener on the other side and I
do understand like dude like I was
talking about this like on JK news the
other day where like I like we see the
effect that a an attractive woman has on
a group of guys right so the way guys
behave when they see a really pretty
girl they start to change their demeanor
a little bit
they obviously pull out the chair a
little more open the doors a bit they
may talk to them a lot sweeter they give
them a lot more intention and I saw that
same effect in some guys like there's
some dudes that are so [ __ ]
good-looking like you see the way that
women treat them - yeah right so like if
like for example like I've been to bars
where I've seen really good-looking
dudes there just didn't standing there
and a girl comes and starts talking to
them like what never seen that's never
ever happened to me yeah you know like
she's just chilling and the guy like has
the option to choose whether he wants to
talk to this girl or not and so I can
understand the appeal of it right like I
get it you know I just kind of like I
don't know like I'm so weird I'm
confused because it's it's true whatever
you do to your face and your body is
your choice you know I just don't like
the message that maybe comes along with
it it's like the messages I could do to
my body whatever I want I'm not hurting
anybody else but at the same time when
it becomes like a societal norm that you
could just change whatever you want it
doesn't teach you number one that you
are beautiful the way that you are it's
teaching to me is teaching the opposite
it's that you're flawed and why don't
you go ahead and drop some money and
change it right and it's just like a
weird business to be in like I don't I
don't really like that like I don't want
I don't like if I have kids right if I
have a daughter specifically just
because I personally believe whether
people can agree or disagree or not that
girls just have a lot of pressure to
look a certain way and behave a certain
way compared to do is right aside from
the machismo [ __ ] that guys have I think
girls get real
judged on the way that they look I know
this for the fact because even I'm at
that point to bar sometimes I see a girl
and I judge them by the way that they
look and I tried not to just because I'm
actually not the best looking dude I
thought I should be the one to judge so
you know like it's just kind of tough
and I don't I wouldn't want my daughter
to have to feel like she has to change
things about the way that she looks all
the times to feel good about herself
yeah but that's tough though because
mainstream media and even even marketing
campaigns for things like makeup or
clothes you can't help but see like what
what what is being projected at you as
the ideal body type or as the ideal look
yeah and so it she's like when you're
slammed with that every single day you
just can't help but think okay I'm not
normal I'm not I'm not like these girls
I don't look like these girls so I must
not be that attractive you know like
it's it's the it's the mindset that's
happened cuz like for me growing up it
was pretty much like that like I think
in the 90s or early 2000s I think the
body type of that era was really skinny
like you were like a stick skinny right
and so at that time like for me is like
because I didn't have that type of body
type I felt really out of place and I
didn't feel like I was pretty I didn't
feel like I was beautiful either yeah
and I just felt like I had to I didn't
really diet but I did try to work out
but I never achieved that particular
body type so then I just kind of gave up
on that right where I was just like well
[ __ ] dude like my body can't necessary
do that we're either that I'm very weak
willed and I don't want to get to that
point where I have to sacrifice how much
I eat or what I do right and so I've
always had this complex with my body
about like oh yeah I don't think I
really fit that I was like oh oh like oh
I see you like fat building up here or
whatever or like in my thighs guys are
like the first place where everything
goes and so I've always had like a very
self-conscious feeling about my legs now
I don't feel it so much anymore because
I've just accepted them and like I like
them because they're strong and they
have muscle and so to me it's like as
long as I can lift things with my legs I
don't feel bad for them yeah and
to your credit I think that's like a
really good thing and that's what I like
right so necessarily what sometimes what
you dislike about yourself doesn't mean
that somebody else won't like it right
right and you know like even like
physical things that people like now
trends change all the [ __ ] time they
do but then when you're just surrounded
but especially in your adolescence yeah
I hope but like it's so impression of
all to you yeah I know like it's just
hard man even like you know I I'm not
fronting either like when I was when I
was in high school you know I was always
a big guy you know I wasn't as big as I
got you know like a year ago I mean that
took time that took a lot of food to get
that big you know but even then like you
know I was like 200 and I think I'm this
weight now that I was in high school and
even then when in a high school I felt
like I was a [ __ ] really fat [ __ ]
guy yeah you know I because I lost a
certain amount of weight towards my
senior year and I was around like 205
pounds 210 which is what I weigh right
now and during that time - I remember I
felt fat and I think like for me - I
used to
I made jokes about it a lot right so for
me the reason why I made jokes about my
weight a lot was because if I could joke
about myself and I could make fun of
myself first before you get to you don't
really have any power on me right
so the jokes already on me I already
know what the jokes are I already know
what you're gonna say and I made humor
out of it right and so for me humor was
a way for me to cope with either with
number one how I felt about my weight
how about number two how I looked and
also how other people were going to
perceive me right so if I could make
people laugh out of something that's a
negative attribute then it's really my
strength right like you can't take
something from me that I don't really
care about as much and so I'd started
identify identify myself as a fat guy
right and it just became very
comfortable for me like I just I
couldn't even picture myself thin like I
didn't know like what the what the [ __ ]
is a skinny David you know and even when
I did get a like pretty fit I got a
little more muscular during my second
year in college it just didn't really
you know feel that way
even when I lost the weight now like I
looked I look into the mirror and I
still see the same light that I was 60
pounds ago you know not in the sense
that I hated it it's just more like like
I don't think I'm thin you know I don't
look I'm just like it's just still David
cuz I still like myself then and I still
love myself now
it's just now physically I just feel
better yeah right so the only way I
could see the difference was when I
would see you I would see something
they're like yo what the [ __ ] you look
hella different I know every freaking
week food every [ __ ] week I see you
I'm just like dude David you're a new
person yeah so like Mariel to shrewsbury
is so [ __ ] funny every time she sees
me till this day like even after I've
lost this weight she just gives me a hug
as she goes I could touch my fingers
you've said that about a thousand times
I don't know if this is a compliment now
are you trying to hurt my [ __ ] pins
she's so funny did you know yeah you
know but to that point like what I've
said is that you know I've learned to I
don't say coke but I've learned to deal
with it in a way that I guess it's kind
of like I meant I dealt with it mentally
first before physically right right yeah
so like I mean that's how it starts
yeah it's hard then like when you're
when you're in high school and you're a
teenager and you see what other people
have it you want and if it's based on
looks sometimes it feels so unattainable
you know I mean why else do people work
out in high school then that aren't in
sports they want to look buff because
they want to look good when they take
their shirts off and they want somebody
be like oh you look [ __ ] good which
is not a bad thing
you know if she's such a hard standard
to hold up damn I just did sports
because I didn't want to be out of shape
that's different to you also like you
possibly could had a dick too you know
you know a lot of people in high school
thought that I was a lesbian even though
I had long hair and like I
oh I guess I wore pants all the time but
not a lot of girls were asked or skirts
or dresses at my school but yeah I feel
like even in college - a lot of people
thought I was a lesbian I mean you have
a very weave like sense to you you know
so you guys don't know what a weird age
is like like it's it's like people what
do you would you describe a weave like
or like or like an old taco type of
thing you know I guess like someone who
is super into like of Korean or Japanese
culture or something well if you're
going to Korea
and there's a different term for that I
was weeaboo isn't it no I think we abou
is still otaku is Japanese isn't that
okay I think we abuse Korean or
something I don't even know how that
term came up but yeah I mean but you're
you when I first met you though you
dressed a lot more girly oh did I yeah
when you were with Tommy you dressed a
lot earlier you had long hair you
dressed a little more feminine
I still like button nose and stuff -
yeah but you had a more feminine style
to you and then later after you guys
broke up or I remember you were hanging
out a lot more with your with your
roommate friend yeah and then you guys
started dressing more similar then you
start going a little more lesbian again
and then you went from lesbian to do
like weeaboo so you went to like three
different changes you went from girly to
like scary biker a lesbian and then a
scary biker a Lisbon you went back to
like just normal I think like how you're
how you're comfortable with dad that's
so strange because um I I saw I knew
that I had different clothing phases but
I've always felt that my tastes have
always been somewhat the same or at
least how I dressed then with long hair
versus when I when I dress with my short
hair it was exactly the same clothes but
then people just called me a bunch but
you look you look like but but it was
like if you saw a picture way back with
me with long hair and I was dating Tommy
at that time I was wearing the same
exact outfit and nobody said anything
maybe though because if you look at some
of the videos you did dress different I
did because when I was graduating
college I was like hey you know what
Julie up can't cuss anymore and you got
to clean up your act can't work graphic
tees anymore you got to start wearing
regular clothes because I was just
trying to like get myself oh yeah and
then I got involved in I saw Joe with
his freaking dog sweater and also you
know maybe graphic tees are cool and
then so I started wearing them again and
I'll think yeah okay this is good yeah
well no nobody should base their fashion
on what Joe wears do Joey
eclectic as [ __ ] has a sweater of a
Shiba Inu Inu on his shirt in the galaxy
yeah like come on you know yeah but you
know what though people in JK say that I
am like the little sister of Joe so
whatever I wear it's like on a similar
when he's probably more out there than
oh he's definitely far out there dude
this will has like a bunch of dirty
flutes and keyboard everybody any kind
of instrument that you were put on your
mouth that he's never cleaned once in
the past six years he plays on JK news
and that [ __ ] is German festive as [ __ ]
he does not care if he's ever gotten a
cold is because he played those
instruments at JK news for sure no but
I'm pretty sure he believes that those
terms are helping him build a stronger
immune Joe Joe could make sense out of
anything you see baffle can convince me
of anything in this earth dude he's just
he's just one of those dudes man
yeah like David you got a cut here put
your hand in mud it makes it feel better
no this will [ __ ] funny when were you
there were you did you go with us when
we went to Maui no okay so when we went
to Maui and you know Joe has eczema
right yeah Joe cracked us the [ __ ] up
dude and Joe knows this [ __ ] to [ __ ]
love this guy he goes you know sometimes
when Joe is like in love with something
right he could find the positive in
anything which is such an amazing
attribute of his right so a lot of his
stuff is mine as mind over matter yeah
so this feels like going into these like
waterfalls in these Lakes and he's like
dude this [ __ ] water is healing my
eczema but you could you could visually
see his eczema is getting worse but
diving into the [ __ ] Lake like he
stars at you saying i'm hearling i'm
hearling and you see his eczema grow
like bigger and bigger but he loves
hawaii so much it makes him feel good
it's like a placebo effect for him i
thought the salt water was supposed to I
don't [ __ ] know dude that dudes
hilarious man I [ __ ] love that guy
man yeah you didn't go to Hawaii with us
no I didn't go to the Maui trip you went
to Oahu the yeah the Hawaii trip that I
went to was for Barden Gio's wedding oh
that's right that was the yeah I think
that's the only time I went to Hawaii
yeah yeah at least with you guys there's
another time I went to Hawaii but it was
like long ago yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
did you when you wait when you went to
Hawaii you were
single or you were still with puppy I
was still Tommy at the time where we had
a house ouu you went to Hawaii with us
before when we were at a different house
I don't think so yeah cuz yeah yeah yeah
it was when you swam across like a
[ __ ] jackass
all across the coral reefs and you
scraped your [ __ ] legs yeah but that
was that was that was not the wedding
that was a different time
so you went twice really yeah you went
once in Hawaii and I remember the time
you went on gos thing cuz Darian took a
photo of you that was super pretty okay
was when you were wearing that dress you
went super long hair right okay I still
have long hair at that time too
yeah and then the other time you went
was when you were with Tommy those two
are separate when when Bart and Jill
were married you were not with Tommy no
I was no you were [ __ ] you were not I
was you weren't you were [ __ ] not I
thank you word that he wasn't oh my god
I don't check it first we have to talk
about it fine okay you might have been
with Tommy with the one with Barton
Gio's wedding right yeah yeah but those
are two separate times because the first
second time that we went with Barton Geo
yeah when Barton geo got married we were
in those hot-ass huts the the the other
time that we were at Hawaii and you swam
across that coral reef [ __ ] and you
chopped up your legs was when we rented
a house together with the basketball
court in the driveway
yes that was two separate times oh yeah
because we stayed in that [ __ ]
plantation with Barton Geo sweater
that's the [ __ ] out yeah I remember
toys but yeah but we were we were
together both times yeah
how come I don't remember Tommy there he
was there though huh at the wedding yeah
yeah I don't remember him there and then
swimming across I remember he was there
too because he didn't go with you yeah
cuz cuz ass is like I'm [ __ ] getting
Tommy I'm packing around
I mean I remember I asked him you want
to go swimming and then he was just like
no I just want to film and I was like
okay I'm just gonna go swim or Joe that
savage dude you were swimming yeah hey I
heard TIFF did it to the the other time
around I thought I wasn't there I think
I was inevitably men like TIFF likes
she's like a thrill junkie yeah which is
kind of interesting because not a lot of
beings excite her but if something gets
her adrenaline going she really really
enjoys it mm-hmm like which is kind of
interesting because you have hobbies
yeah what are your hobbies I've never
asked sleeping honestly like there have
been days where I would just literally
just chill in bed and Nelson get really
annoyed
oh really yeah I like to call it hash
tag bed life and then he was just like
oh my god you need to get out of this
bed I was like but it's so comfortable
here you're just gonna get bedsores one
day did you say that but you like moving
though you were in cross country you
like staying active but they're just
days that you just I want to move at all
mm-hmm I can't do that I feel like I'm
gonna die oh I don't know I just feel
really tired really yeah a lot no dude
kind of you maybe that's why you look so
young Julia is actually 42 years old
guys the the birthday on the Internet is
fall she's 42 [ __ ] years old you're
not 30 yet are you
no what are you 29 this year I'll be 29
so you're 28 right now you did turn 29
yeah one come March that's fine time has
gone by so fast man yeah yeah I met you
when we had the big the the office in
the morning yeah we had that office and
that's when I first met you yeah but
that was when I was like 23 or 24 that's
so [ __ ] crazy dude dude when i when i
first met you i legit thought you were
like a [ __ ] 14 year old and i like i
remember too because i started cracking
up to myself because i kept talking to
her like she was a child
yeah so like I thought okay yeah yeah
yeah like basically taught like it
wasn't condescending but I thought you
were a little kid haha
so I didn't want to say like anything
inappropriate or like joke around too
much in front of you because I didn't
know if you were like a super young
intern right and then I and I think I
found out your age like a couple months
after I was like oh she's an adult
dude I felt so weird and well I mean at
that time to again I was just trying to
be clean I didn't want to have like I
didn't cuss at the time and I was just
trying to be I was trying to be a bit
more professional so yeah that probably
rubbed off on me being really young yeah
I I thought you were a [ __ ] kid dude
do remember uh Lauren yeah so I when I
first met Lauren I keep [ __ ] doing
this because all you [ __ ] girls don't
age whatsoever
I thought Lauren when I first met her
was Ryan's younger sister yeah so we
were in Vegas and then I was like oh so
[ __ ] embarrassing like she was an
editor for JK for JK news and then I I
literally said this to her I was like oh
are you here with your older brother do
you think I am I was like isn't Ryan
your older but she goes no I'm an editor
although because she was walking around
next to him the whole time so I am the
nipple Japanese so I assumed that they
were related so I thought it was like
the Japanese connect this cute little
girl you're Vegas what are you doing
young lady you know no I'm an editor I'm
in college I was like College
it looks like she just graduated junior
high and [ __ ] yeah so like I was a
volunteering for a nonprofit
organization called Relay for Life and I
was coordinators for the volunteers one
year and there was a mom that was
actually a part of the the nonprofit and
she was like sings like oh you know what
what are you up to what's new with you
and I was like oh I'll be graduating in
May she's like oh cool what college are
you going into and I was like oh I'm I'm
graduating college and she was like oh
it's kind of crazy did like how don't
you fools look man like it's it's
interesting though cuz I even even like
every girl that I met in JK I've always
[ __ ] up something cuz like TIFF I
introduced myself to her like four or
five [ __ ] times had no idea who she
was
yeah cuz she changed every time she
changed some braces then after that she
stopped wearing glasses that she wore
makeup the other time I was like who the
[ __ ] is this Iranian girl she's [ __ ]
Mexican I had no idea and then with Gio
you thought that she was a man yeah
because she the way she talks is so
[ __ ] dude like through text I thought
her full name was like Giovanni or some
[ __ ] and then it was just [ __ ] tall
[ __ ] [ __ ] of a giant and I was like
holy [ __ ] it's a girl threw me the [ __ ]
off man okay so other than you thinking
that I was a super young intern yeah
well what else was your first impression
nothing I just was like oh she's a
little girl I didn't really pay much
attention to you right I only do that
because I don't want to invest myself
emotionally at people who aren't gonna
be around right right because it's just
a lot of work on my part right right and
that's how the same thing was for when
TIFF introduced us to Isaac when he was
a kid yeah so when I first met Isaac I
didn't really talk to him much because
one of the things that I saw growing up
a lot so I have a lot of friends back
from Sacramento who have kids right or
they I'm gonna say they have kids but
they I've had friends who have dated
women or guys who have kids and then
through friendship we become attached to
that kid that they have and then for me
it just kind of was so [ __ ] up that
this kid starts calling you uncle starts
calling you all this other stuff and
then they split and they break up so I
didn't know what his emot-- what Casey's
emotional
attachment was to Isaac at that point
yet so I didn't want to invest myself
emotionally into this kid or to this new
girl because why would I do that it's
[ __ ] up for the kid is [ __ ] up for
everybody else so I kind of kept her at
at an arm's length and I also kept Isaac
and I love kids too so I really wanted
to play with Isaac and I [ __ ] love
that kid so I was just like so weird
about it you know didn't really say hi
to him too much I just said hi Isaac and
I didn't really play with him but then
it was kind of rough cuz I like Maness
gets cute like a good kid yeah you know
so that you would do to the men like
after you saw and witnessed me sticking
around for many years I was like this
girl's really fun dude he's a really fun
little girl did [ __ ] snot-nosed brat
you know yeah and then you know what
said yeah when I first met you like I
don't know I forgot like what it was
exactly that kind of cuz you were
interning at the time and you weren't
working full-time for JK no I wasn't
because I was still working part-time at
a restaurant and at like at like a
Korean Korean Brazilian barbecue - right
yeah yeah yeah mm-hmm I was working at
those yeah you're working uh it was part
time as a waitress yeah yeah it was hard
time for them and then I had one other
job that I was doing at that time - that
was also part time and so I was doing
that and JK on top cuz I cuz I needed to
make money
now I remember yo Tommy I'm gonna put
you on blast real quick cuz this [ __ ] is
so [ __ ] funny Oh what happened here
oh yeah so I'm gonna put you on blast
locally so Tommy is like the funniest
[ __ ] dudes now you check him out like
his great cinematographer you know he
used to work for just very [ __ ]
talented but this [ __ ] dweeb
dude cracked me the [ __ ] up Tommy I'm
gonna get you on the [ __ ] too just so
you could explain your [ __ ] self so
when Julia worked for JK films at the
time as she was an intern nobody knew
she was a [ __ ] intern at all
it was so [ __ ] funny and so like what
was told to me at the time was that wait
will you he got you as an intern right
yeah he got you as an intern without
telling Bart and Joe that you were being
an intern for JK film yeah but that was
my assumption because
he was saying oh cool you got the
internship position and I was like dope
but then he did tell me that he was
going to train me on how to become an
intern for JK or like which which
doesn't exist there isn't a pre training
program to become an intern for JK so
literally what this fool was doing is
that he thought she was super [ __ ]
cute and he wanted to be around her so
he lied to her and told her she could be
an interpreter K without telling Barton
Jo I thought that [ __ ] was the it's kind
of cute but it's [ __ ] hilarious dude
it's like bro what the [ __ ] were you
thinking
so the first time I met Jo and yes was
at oh my god a wax shoot mm-hmm and um
it was a featuring Asian mom and there
Jo right and so I remember I walked in
on set and I went up to Jo was like hey
Jo I'm Julia I'm your new intern and the
Jo was like you could see for like a
split second I was like what the [ __ ]
and then he was like oh yeah yeah cool
nice to meet you you're like really well
but then I was just like you know who
you were at all no he didn't
and then like I mean yeah and so then
like I think they had a talk with Tommy
and then like I guess things are kind of
like clarified and and then like they
they kind of brought me on to like their
shoots just to see like how well I do
and how well I fit in and and what my
work ethic was like and then over time
they're like okay this chick school
she's not like somebody that just here
because you know she's like a huge huge
fan it's just that you know she's here
because she likes what we do and you
were you were a blessing in disguise
yeah and it kind of really worked out
well for Tommy because that dude was
just he was just trying to get with you
that's it I just thought you were super
[ __ ] cute and he wanted to have you
around but he was too nervous or shy or
too much of a [ __ ] say hey I think
you're cute let's go out on a date which
really wouldn't have been much you know
and so the only thing he could do is
just have you around by saying oh well
this girl is interested in JK so I'm
gonna use this to keep her around and
then maybe I'll slide in then hey maybe
we should be together type of stick and
guess what [ __ ] is it [ __ ] work
because they did go out for like a
couple years [ __ ] Tommy worked that
[ __ ] dweeb game
homie you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
better explain yourself on this podcast
when I bring you on you dude what is he
coming on I'm gonna tell him to come on
man because I need him to explain that
story that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] funny yeah
yeah what is this dude talking about
dude that should crack me up yeah I
remember when I first met him it was at
the 66 night market that's why I asked
him if like JK was looking for interns
in production mm-hmm and um I remember
when I went out to a movie like oh hey
are you Thai from JK and then he was
like oh yeah uh your and I was like you
don't know me I'm just a fan so he like
kind of played it off as like he knew
who I was of course Tommy but he did it
so yeah what a [ __ ] goofy ass guy dude
yeah hey it [ __ ] worked though you
guys went out for - almost - almost two
[ __ ] years he was here first like
serious relationship he was my longest
one yeah cuz cuz there was one guy that
I was in college that I dated for maybe
two weeks or so two weeks yeah yeah it
was yeah I was really short because um
we worked together at a rest at the
Brazilian steakhouse and he was like I
think he might have been like two years
younger than me yeah a little cradle
robber did he like that like that baby
dick cute um he was a break dancer but I
think at the time like when I was dating
him and when I was getting to know him
like all he could talk about was one of
his best friends and I was like damn
dude this guy's head over heels for his
best friend and so like I'm not a girl
that's his best friend Yeah right and
then like I mean like to me I was just
like you know you sure don't know like
talk to her you know me there is
something there and he's like no no no
there is it and I was like the [ __ ]
weirdo but then what he wasn't saying
that - like keep me around it was just I
think he was really trying to move on
from her because maybe he was hung up on
her for too long or whatever and so I
was just like oh okay so that we were
like dating for a week and I just
remember telling him is a hateful on the
school of disclaimer like if there's a
point where you're not interested in
dating me just tell me like I'm not
gonna get hurt
yeah like I mean you know like I'd
rather not waste your time and I'd
rather
have my time wasted so if the moment you
start questioning whether you want to
date me or not I feel like that's
already a bad sign so we should probably
end it right yeah and so first week was
cool second week was a little weird um
not quite sure what exactly happened but
I think he started having thoughts and
like kind of doubts about like us dating
and then I was just like okay so the
night I message she was like hey let's
let's talk like we should talk right I
have a feeling that something's really
off and I was like stressing a lot about
it too right and um he was just like
yeah um yeah I don't know if like I
couldn't continue to do this and I was
like okay cool so why didn't you tell me
that you tell me that yeah you little
dumb yeah and I was like well how long
did you feel that way he was like after
the first week and I was like what and
then like so I wasn't hurt about the
fact that like he wasn't interested in
dating me yeah I was more hurt about
like whoa what the [ __ ] dude what well
what did I do wrong in the sense of like
I laid it out there for you III try to
make it as hands-off as possible you
know like if you weren't interested you
could or just said so how old was he at
the time how old were you ah I think I
was 22 at the time anything he was 20 oh
dude that's what that's what young kids
do right you know so I mean so at that
time it was just like I was more angry
at the fact of those like he couldn't
even like tell me like that he wasn't
interested right versus like cuz I think
he was too afraid of hurting my feelings
anything that's what got me frustrated
cuz I was like bro I already told you up
front
yeah but you know when you're a young
person too you don't really know what to
do and I think like a lot of the times
at a young age confrontation is
something that kids who run away from
anyway I take that back not even kids
people in general I at me like adults
they just people don't like
confrontation which is actually a decent
attribute to happy and what I mean by
that is like you kind of pick and choose
your battles a lot right but some people
they run away from confrontation so much
they pay just rather let things fester
and get worse and worse and worse until
it blows up in their [ __ ] face so
it's actually a good thing you actually
contacted him and with you you were very
straightforward about it because if not
that would drag on for like four months
or some right I mean it was stressing me
out cuz I was like
what's going on like what's happening
what is he feeling what am I feeling it
was it was just a whole bunch of like
emotional like stress that I didn't want
in my life and I was like okay this
needs to end right now it's so
interesting yeah and then people at work
were like also see you guys aren't
dating anymore and I was just like I was
like oh are you okay and I was like yeah
I'm fine and okay homie thought yeah
I'll try to get some fresh dick without
that fresh ziplock did take that [ __ ]
penis straight off that zip lock homey
yeah she should stop making this table
so much but um that's so interesting so
you worked at a Brazilian restaurant you
worked you were a waitress and then you
kind of fell into the hole JK thing
which by the way is not an easy task to
do because I think like the world that
you came from it's so different from
this world like this world is is all
about your destiny is literally in your
hands yes even like specifically working
for this company it's it's not so
clear-cut right so the great thing about
like working for JK for a lot of people
who have been in this company from the
beginning and you know there's - it's
like opportunity there's always there
you just have to be a strong enough
individual to voice your opinions and
take those opportunities right which is
very different from corporate world
right corporate world like I feel like
sometimes like there are steps that
people let you know that this is your
limit that this is what you can go to
you had to push towards it but with JK
it's more like hey I feel like we I
could do this for the channel or do this
for the company I want to create this
position can I do it you just have to be
a strong enough individual to mention it
and that's like a good and bad thing
because you you have to be responsible
enough to control your destiny right
because even for you and a lot of people
started wondering this it's like you
when you started doing JK news after a
while you've disappeared which I don't
know which I don't that wasn't even
fully explained to me either I just
remembered that number one it was either
becoming difficult for you or there was
something I don't know what it was but
then you you chose to go a different
path and then what it wasn't a right fit
yeah because it was a very stressful for
you or yeah I mean it was it was a whole
bunch of things so like um what is it
okay so
jakie news was happening around the time
that I was interning and it was
pretty new and when I sat in I was
literally filling in for the previous
host and then soon I became a full-time
host and I didn't actually expect myself
to be a host at the time because
literally my goal and there was to learn
about production work and to mainly stay
behind cameras right and so being the
table sorry okay
and so when I was uh asked to be like
hey can you host cuz you know you've
done a couple and you'd done a few and
and look and you did pretty well and I
was like oh sure if you need someone to
fill in the spot I'll I'll do it and so
I did the hosting for awhile and then I
remember like hosting got really crazy
so instead of ten article days it was 15
and then became 15 to 20 and then after
20 became 40 and I think at one point it
was like 60 I think we were considering
80 I don't remember if we did it or if
we did it one day but yeah I remember 60
being like a lot of articles in one day
and you were there you were yeah we were
there for a really long time from yeah
9:00 a.m. all the way till 12:00
midnight right and so I think me doing
that so often I think it just I don't
know like I think it just got to me to
the point where I felt like my hosting
skills plateaued and that I and and and
it wasn't something I was interested in
either right like I never wanted to be a
host of any talk show I didn't want to
be a host of like any production side of
things yeah right so then like to me I
was just like okay well I feel like
these are my limits as a host and I
plateaued and at that time like TIFF was
also transitioning into and like she was
hosting as well and then seeing her host
was making me things like okay I think
TIFF is actually a better fit than I am
right in this and I think like over time
I felt like there was so much stress
going into the news articles because we
had to find a certain amount every week
and if we did in it kind of felt like a
failure at least for me on my end
there's a lot of anxiety that went into
it because like doctors not like there's
not any like good articles out right now
and there's not any like light-hearted
ones because right now like in that time
that world was miserable yeah right and
so it I saw I I personally felt like I
was struggling and I'm trying to make
something work that wasn't working for
me necessarily yeah and so I think with
all that anxiety building up and then
filming on the day of and then
forgetting all the information or like
the notes that I took weren't like
helpful notes or like maybe
mispronouncing things are stuttering a
lot right like all those little things
started like getting to me and then like
it didn't like I'm not gonna lie I
didn't help when I saw like really
negative comments ah yeah just
remembering feeling sorry guys yeah yeah
so it was just like I think with that in
the combination of me knowing that I
didn't really necessarily yeah started
out wanting to be a host oh yeah it
really got to me and really affected me
and so yeah it was really hard to
because I didn't really want to let the
team down hence I was like well I've
been working on this for so long as like
why can't I improve or what what is
wrong with me like why why did I why did
I hit this putt - oh that I'm not quite
sure yeah that that happened and so um
at that time I was like okay one I'm
getting really stressed - I'm getting a
lot of anxiety you weren't happy yeah
and then the next part was like I want
to continue to be on the show to help
further it but I felt it got so bad to
the point where I started getting
anxiety where people were I felt like
people would literally click away like
maybe it's a narcissist narcissistic
thought but it was just like there were
comments where people were saying like
oh I see Julie I click away and in
tamils like dude I don't want the
business to go down because of me and
how sucky my hosting skills are yeah and
so or like how my hosting skills became
over time and so because of that like I
just felt my conditioning getting worse
and I didn't really want to beat a dead
horse anymore in a sense at least for me
right and and it's like um and I think
it's just like a lot of it has to do
with my mental perspective right and at
that time it wasn't very good and so I
felt like it was best for me to step
away from jakie news yeah than to
continue on with it not knowing what
exactly to do so so hard and you know
that's the thing like you know and it's
hard because I could tell you as much as
I want like the people who leave those
comments are trash human beings you know
but sometimes it just doesn't [ __ ]
matter like especially when you're
already going through so much [ __ ]
[ __ ] number one like being a part of
something like JK news is not easy you
know everybody thinks that they can do
it everybody thinks that oh if we bring
up an article we could talk about it too
and just do it it's like well if if
people could have done it they would
have done it by now right right they
really would have because I mean just to
put it in perspective for people like I
always tell people when they listen to
JK news number one we are not a [ __ ]
news source yeah it's about conversation
and jokes and friends talking the the
news article is just a thought and the
subject for us to bounce our own ideas
off of right that's it you know that's
why it's called just kidding news the
[ __ ] company's called just kidding
you [ __ ] [ __ ] right and but the
people who are leaving these comments
you know you know they do it because
they want to get a reaction out of you
right and like and like there's some
comments where I do take as actual
critique where it's just like you know
maybe you should remind yourself to put
something like this in the notes or like
maybe try to do tongue twisters so that
you won't cetera as much you know like
things like that were like helpful
things or it's just like things like
maybe you should I don't I don't [ __ ]
remember but there's just like there's
some that were actually good advice that
like I would try to like apply into my
hosting but like other ones we're just
like pure hate and I was like [ __ ] am I
making the show worse
no I mean you never made the show worse
it's just that these people and also to
even when people give critique and
advice about something you haven't done
it you are not in that position so
who the [ __ ] are you to ask like like
they're like okay try this tongue
twister [ __ ] have you [ __ ] done 60
[ __ ] articles a day have you tried to
memorize 60 article with over a hundred
people in a hundred stories in one
[ __ ] day yeah have you tried that I
guarantee you haven't and on top of that
- performing - camera doing this with a
one-hour break in between and what
people don't know when we were filming
we were [ __ ] filming from 9 [ __ ]
a.m. to 1 a.m.
yeah that's how much we were working we
were brain dead and blasted and the next
day we had to pick up and do our other
other projects to filming whatever that
it was it was not easy
it was hard and there was a certain
point where we were doing so many
articles we were doing that twice a
[ __ ] week
yeah and everybody oh that's just once a
week have you tried talking and just
trying to be funny and entertaining for
[ __ ] like 14 hours straight yeah it
is not easy and so when people like
write these things in need advice like
sometimes it comes from a very good
place completely understandable even for
my channel I say hey can you guys let me
know what you think about these upload
times that's where stuff like your
opinions really matter right but when
somebody comes up and they look at your
job in your position say this is what
you can do to make it better it's like
cool you are not somebody who's in that
position to tell me how to make it
better like for me when I did stand-up
comedy I asked comics how to make my
stand-up better right right because they
do it they understand they understand
what the give-and-take is when you go up
you're holding a mic you're performing
how to make jokes hit how to pace
yourself those are the things that
matter the most and you know to your
credit - it's just [ __ ] hard like
number one you're stressed the [ __ ] out
so these small little things it's just
the last straw on the camel's hump it's
just gonna [ __ ] break you yeah you
know and it's just it would I didn't
know like how much you were going
through just because for me when it
comes to JK news that's just the part
that I played right and so afterwards I
had to go deal with my own [ __ ] you know
so for me I thought things were going
great I thought things were perfectly
fine oh I mean like for the most part
like I try not to have so much negative
feelings about JK news it was just more
of like alright well my chapter here is
done even taking news I think I've come
to a place where I felt like I've helped
the channel enough to the best of my
abilities yeah
and it's like you know I help to get it
running up to the point that it was and
I think in terms of the way that I host
I think I don't feel like necessarily I
want to improve on that and like to Jake
a new setting right which is great right
you you came to that conclusion on your
own which is awesome right and so like
I've I've literally mentally prepared
myself and talked myself through it
where I was like it's not your fault but
it's just like it's it's so hard because
I feel like I've always grown up with
that feeling of like oh it's your fault
if you can't complete something and so
to me it it took a while for me to be
okay and say like hey it's not your
fault it's cool like you've worked
really hard and you've got to Jake and
use that to this point and literally
like I think it's okay to walk away
because you're unhappy yeah and so um I
literally had a talk with TIFF and I
asked her if she would be okay to take
the workload of the other half of the
articles and she said yeah like she was
down and she seemed excited about it and
I was like great because I think yeah
it's like I can't do it and I think
you're a great host for it I think
you're a better fit for it too
and then um talked to bard and Jo about
it and like they they thought that like
I wanted to be on news because I enjoyed
it and I continued to stay they didn't
know that I did it because I was filling
in a position and like look I'm not
gonna lie like Jake enews was fun yeah
like it was fun like if I could stay
like sure right but then a part of me
just feels like but I don't know if I
really necessarily fit that branding
because I feel like my opinions are very
neutral like I don't necessarily lean on
one side or the other it's just more of
like to me it's like I like to see both
sides and then I'm just like okay like I
see I see your point like yeah you you
go here you go here to me it's like I
feel like it's case-by-case yeah right
so like yeah and that's that's anything
in comedy or when it comes to like
content like that then people don't get
it it's like well why can't you just
stay neutral on things because if we
stay neutral on things you wouldn't want
to [ __ ] watch us that's how that's
how comedy is you make a point you stick
[ __ ] to it and you find the humor in
it right so this is where I see a lot of
comics fail they're like well I don't
want to
and people blah blah blah you not-there
be socially smart about the content that
you put out a hundred percent but you
can't be wishy-washy about your [ __ ]
yeah you know and that's that's not easy
for a lot of people it's actually very
difficult I mean to your credit what I
really what I really do enjoy is that
you actually figured out like hey this
isn't for me and you figured out a way
to remove yourself from something that
wasn't making you happy which is hard
because the hard part about that is that
sometimes like I think in your case
specifically because if you're upgrading
and how I was like brought up to is that
when we move away when we move away from
this it's not like I'm doing this
because it's better for me you almost
feel selfish sometimes you feel like I'm
doing this for myself and I'm letting
this team down okay
and so it hurts because now you feel
like I'm being a selfish human being
because I should be thinking about the
team and because I haven't and because I
failed everybody else has to suffer
right but that wasn't the case you know
and it's just hard to move away from
that that thought sometimes because
number one you are a team player and
you've always been a great team player
so what people don't know about Julia -
when I was doing a lot of see Julia
actually used to produce for me it was
fun you did a really great job I bought
a lot of [ __ ] and I returned a lot if
that's not what the gangster is baby you
know but you know everybody has to
figure out their strengths yeah and
that's a good thing you know even for me
too you know how I can relate to this is
that I always tell people - something
that I used to do when I was younger I
used to look it's kind of like that
saying of like you look at you you look
at what somebody else has - but you
forget to see what you have mm-hmm right
so like for me the reason why I decided
to not do music as much and do comedy is
because I kept on looking at music as
something like oh I could still do it
but it wasn't making me happy that
wasn't fun for it anymore but because I
felt like I had the skill for it and
then people wanted to see it I kept on
putting on this pressure that I still
should continue to do music constantly
but what I had to realize about music is
like for me and my ability as a musician
unless I dive into it a thousand million
percent I'm just always gonna be a
mediocre musician
yeah and I'm only doing it because I
feel like I'm failing right and that's a
terrible way to couldn't pursue an art
yeah that's how I felt like in
my college days because my program was 5
years long and I studied animation and
so I was learning how to draw in
traditional like so 2d enemies yeah yeah
and it wasn't until my last year of
college when I realized that I didn't
necessarily want to do that per se like
I I liked animation I still want to be
somewhere a part of entertainment in
that area but like what if young julia
had did a little bit more research the
position that i wanted to be in was
somewhere in production like whether it
be like a production management or
whatever yeah in in animation right and
because like and I only realized this
because I went out to like this art club
hangout thing that was happening at
Downtown Disney or someplace and we were
all hanging out and there's this one guy
from Fullerton he was telling me that he
was interning at this one animation
studio and he was doing production work
and I asked him what that was and he was
like oh you know you just file papers
and you communicate in between teams and
yeah you um you you talk to them about
about things and you try to piece things
together to get things done immediately
in my head I was like wow that sounds
really fun yeah and then I was like oh
cool how do you like it he's like nah
that's just really boring I was like Oh
sounds boring and in heels like gala
mean like whoever wants to do that right
and I was like yeah it was so boring and
so so at that time it really opened up
my eyes where I was just like oh [ __ ]
like I know I have the skill set to be
an animator but I don't really find any
fulfillment in my own artwork or in my
own creation yeah like you appreciate
the art right but what is not so much in
the sense of like oh I don't I can't see
myself doing the art part for the rest
of my life though like like I think if
hard to do the art part for the rest of
my life I would literally have to be
like a follower but if you want me to be
creative and something like I feel like
that's the portion of me where I feel
like I lack a lot and it's like I know
that I can plot artists or like that I
can probably practice to be creative but
I think for me it's like did you still
love enough to do that yeah I didn't I
didn't and so I think I I personally
found a lot more joy and pushing people
to get their projects done and seeing
that result seeing them happy made me
happy so with that in mind I was like
man maybe I should go into production so
in my last year I just finished up with
animation
that's when I started but you're great
at production though like production is
not an easy job
it is production is [ __ ] hard man
like yeah I think when when people if
you guys don't know anything about
producers but we work on it on a smaller
scale
but my biggest thing that I love about
producers like know is not an answer
there's not an option
yeah and if you're if you have a
producer that works for you and they say
that they're a producer they come back
with nothing they're [ __ ] trash yeah
don't ever come back with nothing
you come back with [ __ ] options if we
if we want a certain prop that's there
that's just impossible to get then you
come back with 17 other [ __ ] options
that we can choose from because whether
or not you provide it or not we still
have to shoot we have to keep on moving
on some preparation is a big key that's
why there's coordinators there's
producers there's assistant producers
there's all these other stuff that this
back-end that requires like film or any
type of project to be done producers are
like the backbone of this [ __ ] you know
which is a very [ __ ] difficult job
and you know it's hard man like you know
I like I completely understand where
you're coming from from these comments
because like even for me it's not like I
don't get affected by comments it's just
I have an ability just to laugh at it
it's like [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you know to me I mean there's something
that I'm able to laugh at yeah it's just
most people don't yeah most people don't
most people take everything to heart I I
get irritated at comments all the
[ __ ] time it's like who the [ __ ] are
you you trashbag like i immediately
think that but 2019 Davis show says and
we're only gonna respond the positive
comments or if I do respond to
negativity
I'm gonna respond to it in an in a
decent manner cuz before I would just
trash people and you know the problem
that I had with that it was developing a
bad habit where I would trash people not
because I'm angry is because it would
make me smile to make somebody upset so
I would becoming a troll I was become
the thing I hated the most right oh [ __ ]
I'm trolling the troll now yeah what am
i doing I'm like what am i doing like
I'm doing something that that I say that
I hate that other people do is also
being a hypocrite and that's why I'm
trying not to do it to the best of my
[ __ ] ability I'm trying my best
so how so how's it looking for 2019 it's
very hard it's very hard I feel it
bubbling inside and I'd like to I'm
gonna trash this [ __ ] living germ
like I'm going to literally find this
bro like sometimes I think like I can't
wait
I had this join once right where I for
some reason had the ability so when
somebody would leave a comment like I
had connections to like the FBI and they
could find where they live and I showed
up to a house and I literally beat the
[ __ ] out of like a fourteen-year-old kid
are you serious the kid was huge though
he was a kid she was like huge old are
you I was my age so as a 30 year old man
I get the [ __ ] out of a 14 year old I'll
tell you this I woke up very satisfied
after I beat his ass in the dream their
parents said thank you one of the best
dreams ever dude beating up 14 year olds
was so [ __ ] defenseless and he was my
size so I didn't feel so bad pummeling
the living [ __ ] [ __ ] out oh I dream
about the [ __ ] dumbest things that
was so satisfying well I think your body
is really trying hard to suppress you
from like verbally that's one shot in
public and so it's taking it out and you
know I'm also trying to I might curse a
lot but I'm trying to reduce it by like
50% not because I have anything wrong
against cursing I feel like it's my
fault actu much now yeah and it's just
becoming too fluid like I'm not picking
and choosing when I'm using it it's just
becoming too much of a part of my
vernacular yeah that's how I feel too
yeah so it's like okay pick and choose
your cursing out David because now
you're just cursing all the damn time
and Muriel hates it dude Muriel is just
like the sweetest [ __ ] girl that I
know so when I curse it hurts her
feelings and I see her cringe and like
it makes me feel bad dude I don't know
why she chose me out of all people like
it's so funny because the the qualities
that she wants to see in a good person I
don't have like I don't have those
qualities but what qualities of Mara you
like that make you oh she has all the
qualities that I like oh I see yeah I
mean but sometimes I feel like I don't
have the quality she wants yeah but it's
cuz I make her happy so that's like the
over scoping thing it's like okay he
makes me happy he's a good person
you know cuz she sees all the best
qualities in me and she sees the worst
it's just sometimes the the worst
qualities are very glaring you just get
her face all the time I remember the
first time I met her you do seeing a
skit for you
I hit on that girl with a [ __ ]
fierceness dude I saw all these heart
beams hitting at her and I just see the
bounce off of her you know out of all
the JK people nobody has ever seen me
flirt with a girl is that for you
Wow I'm honored I'm honored because I
just remember like I'm very aggressive I
remember I was watching you I was like
oh that's not time to I was still kind
of getting to know you it was just like
Oh David's natural like that but I just
feel like it's a little but because like
I'm a very friendly person yeah you are
I'm super friendly but I'm friendly in a
platonic way when I flirt it's different
like you could tell there's a difference
you know I I saw I remember I was in the
bathroom with Muriel and I was trying to
fix up her hair and you said I know you
bought the you said what's up and you
poked her a few times and she like
smacked you a few times she's a Gipping
[ __ ] out of you oh she did say yeah
she's like get out of here yeah she was
she was she was fireplace she liked me
I'll give a like
but that's when that's when I decided to
really pursue her and you know at that
time too I wasn't thinking about getting
with anybody else like I was planning to
stay single until this age this is the
age that I said I was gonna start dating
30 Wow yeah and then um I just didn't
have an interest in being with anybody
else so then what made you go for her at
that time like was it love at first
sight or what love at first sight it was
just it's I always had this thought of
why the [ __ ] not right so why lose an
opportunity because you put the the
barrier or the boundary in your head
that you were only gonna date when
you're 30 what kind of stupid construct
is that if you see somebody that you're
attracted to and you feel something yeah
then give it a girl she gave you
butterflies when you first saw her I
don't know if it was butterflies cuz I
was a second time I met her the first
time I met her was actually I had them
footage of it there's a clip of it yeah
and she and I like I do I was working on
set so she was a PA yeah so I you know
what I'm working on he's working yeah
and then but this time I was I didn't
have to direct or any have to do any of
that stuff somebody else got to do
direct and they were taking control so I
could just be more myself and then I saw
her and she was super funny she was very
fun to have around and I thought she was
really cute yeah lo and behold four
years later were together okey you are
you know I am I am honored to help
witness the very beginnings yeah
you're the only person in JK that
actually has seen me pursue a girl oh my
gosh she was so beautiful yeah you know
like I'm like because if I'm around you
guys I'm just around you guys so I'm
just I'm just David you know but
obviously like you know I don't think
nobody's ever seen me like flirt with a
girl or even like just not be goofy
David because usually I'm just goofy
David I'm not really you know I'm not
very hyper sexual you know I'm just like
always joking around having fun I'm very
like mother hadn't like you know what I
mean I'm like that I call myself mother
hen I get mother hen hugs like I'm
always like comforting and but you know
with her it was different on my dude I
think I was there both times when she
was a PA and when she was you're
producing that one too huh yeah well
that's right first time I saw her you
did a great job at that thank you
thank you and then and then it was the
other one without just do it right yeah
that's when YouTube was really fun yeah
well I still love doing like the podcast
is amazing man because I get to know
more about your story and then this is
just a way for me to like reconnect with
people yeah I mean like it was dope I
felt like I mean I'm very thankful for
the opportunity gave me to produce
yourself because I think at that time
you were still kind of trying to collect
your team together yeah
at the time but you also knew that I was
interning yeah it was just like I mean I
don't know what made you decide to take
a shout at me so you work with JK and
then for me I like building teams
together so there are a lot of people
that I have worked that that are great
at what they do and they don't take
instruction very well so I'm a very
particular human being I'm very
particular like you were I remember
there was one time you wanted me to find
a Korean actress or some actress that
spoke Korean yeah and I was like can't
you just teach her the lines and you
were like no she needs something because
like [ __ ] yeah it's like I remember I
kept coming back at you with that you're
like just be Korean I'm like no and then
he was like then no and I was like wow
and I just member got frustrated I was
like [ __ ] dude I wonder Davis getting
frustrated me because I'm bringing all
these actresses that were Korean yeah
well the thing about me so I'm very
straight for so if I was like upset or
frustrated I would tell you like hey
you're frustrating me oh but if I don't
say it that's why I'm I always tell
people like unless I [ __ ] tell you
like hey I'm upset or I
there has to be a verbal note to it
because I don't want people to be up in
the air about how I feel about them yeah
I might be a little like feel a little
weird but it's not nothing that I'm
angry or upset about if I'm angry I'll
take somebody aside as like hey like
there's something off between us right
you know but how how when does that ever
happen I actually don't get angry like
that often like if I get angry because I
did something stupid you know it's not
because somebody else like my friend my
friends rare I don't think anybody in
Jake has ever gotten me mad once all
that's awesome nobody has ever made me
angry JK that's good there's no reason
to it's a it's a friendly working
environment and the great thing about
our friendship that I have especially
with like Bart and Joe and then miss Ike
I think we just sometimes when we [ __ ]
up is just a [ __ ] up and we just move on
like it's you know what's the big deal
if it's a big deal then we'll talk about
it and I'm probably [ __ ] up multiple
times when they probably just gave me a
pass but just maybe maybe I'm just the
one that I'm psyched I'm never angry at
these guys I [ __ ] up a lot though but
you know yeah yeah it's I mean that's so
cool like I didn't know that that that
that whole I didn't know the whole JK
news things and how much like you were
dealing with at that time that's so much
to deal with like being on social media
is such a big beast to deal with like
emotionally it's so [ __ ] hard yeah I
think around that time too it was really
hard for me to post just because I was
like do it I need something that I can
hold on to that I feel like it's me yeah
yeah I mean that's a good thing though
like I'm so I'm so glad that you figured
out what you wanted you so what's your
next step then so currently right now
I'm actually producing JK party with
Brandon that's right so there's actually
gonna be some exciting things happening
like we have a plan that we want to
achieve and I think hopefully later down
the line don't hold me to it but we are
gonna try really hard to try to make
five videos out on that channel a week
[Music]
yeah that's pretty awesome though yeah
it's really cool yeah and then like yeah
me and Brandon we have like a 50-50
partnership so it just feels like like
an equal stria it's like an equal on
that yeah that's something that you get
to do that you enjoy which is producing
yeah yeah yeah dude JK party man alright
well I mean are you gonna come on like
what about Massa
what is that
what about mafia I don't hate JK Party
the channel I hate I like watching it I
don't like being in it I don't like
games
I don't like board game done like any of
that [ __ ] never do what what is there a
game that you do enjoy absolutely not
I hate I hate games like that it's it's
okay I don't know I don't know what it
is it's just so I wants it it's not
corny it's more like I didn't grow up
with it so I don't have an attachment to
the games like that like the stuff that
I like is basketball Muay Thai
these are games that I enjoy so then if
we decide to have a basketball
tournament oh [ __ ] yeah like if you do a
JK party outdoors yeah a ball basketball
yeah I'm a hundred percent down okay you
know but if it's like board games mafia
and stuff like I introduced mafia to you
guys right and that was like a fun
Church game yeah and then we played it
so much I got tired of it and like I
just don't maybe an else also because
like I don't know I've never really
liked board games man okay then what
about cards against humanity' but still
love you that's a card board game I
don't like that [ __ ] you don't like it
but you get to talk [ __ ] about people
seeing what drunk zone is stupid wow you
guys here here first you know all right
you guys want David's OTP want to keep
it all the time this is this is the
answer that I get all the time that's
[ __ ] crazy
well people could try to get me wanted
me to keep this channel get sketches and
sketches and [ __ ] I still didn't do it
so no I'm just saying this is the inside
scoop you know the reason why Dave is
not on all the time yeah like JK party
is not my damn thing like it's not
something I enjoy and that's like
another thing that I think that uh I
kind of learn how to do is just if I
don't enjoy just don't do it you know
like I like JK Party the channel I think
is a dope channel it's super
entertaining we had food ones what if we
decide to invite send foods on to JK
party Tim already came on I mean it's
just a matter of time of you and him
together I'll think about it we'll see
if I'm in the mood I'll hit you guys up
I'll text you guys and be like hey let's
get me on a JK party I feel like what
what about like a nice friendly text
every like three months you guys could
try well work it worth what can
everybody find you at Kalia well at you
mean for like Instagram
on my Instagram that's called X blue
apples with a Z at the end so
complicated yeah that's a name that I've
kept for like many years so I'm going to
continue to keep it for many years and
not change it to my actual name thank
you so find her on Instagram Oh YouTube
- it's been active [ __ ] out of here
you're active on your YouTube hello yes
reason why I don't believe this [ __ ]
[ __ ] she recorded stuff when we went
to Japan together four years ago and
still isn't released no its release all
of them there's the last one coming out
the spiny today actually oh great job
four years is all it took yeah why I
don't [ __ ] believe or do you want to
talk about somebody about false promises
you are a you are a bringer of lives how
dare you thanks David you know I'm not a
perfect human being yeah I try I try to
set these goals up and I try to meet
them but if I don't meet them you know
what I'm sorry guys I don't care what
that's right I tried but you know I
worked something out I figured something
out that worked for me
I got an editor and he just edits my
stuff so I don't have to look at my face
that's that's perfect so check her out
on her YouTube which is the same as her
Instagram yes X blue apples with a Z
idea enjoy that see her daily life julia
is one of my favorite favorite people
with JK I've always connected to this
girl on some weird [ __ ] level one
time though I'm out we should end this
but there's so many things to talk about
with her do one time she and I she just
came over just to chill for a second and
eat and then we watched the whole anime
series like like 12 a.m. together yeah
that was insane and I still don't I
still don't even understand that anime
but it was so trippy dude it was called
devil man crybaby would you say it was a
remake of it and it's so [ __ ] trippy
the animations trippy as [ __ ] - and it's
just like on some other level [ __ ] but
we literally watched the whole series
together in one [ __ ] stage yeah
because it was it ended every episode
ended in a way where you're like wait
what what the [ __ ] was happening yeah it
was so there's like titties an issue
they say such a weird but is that yeah
its sexual but it's not like it's so
weird man and people [ __ ] on anime
because they think is for like geeks and
you're completely wrong there's so much
artistry story that that film steals
from all the [ __ ] time you want to
talk about composition and lighting see
what they do when they when they do
these 2d animations dude it's it all
comes based off for like real-life [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] amazing man shoutouts to
[ __ ] anime people who watch that
stuff if you don't watch it you think
it's wack as [ __ ] you can go lay in
front of a car a great anime to get you
guys started to watch is Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood I like both you
didn't like the other one the other ones
okay but both okay it's good Brotherhood
is the actual storyline what you're
talking about the first one of the
second one
Brotherhood is the second animated
series the first one was so [ __ ] good
though it was darker this yeah in a way
it was darker yeah I know you like how
it ended in the first one it tore my
heart it made me so set and I like that
too it was so dark I enjoyed it yeah I
liked like really dark [ __ ] to makes me
think a lot but the second one the
animation was great too yeah I liked the
story in the second one better because
it definitely made more sense yeah it
was easier to understand yes yes so I
would highly recommend Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood and for me if you
guys like this this is has nothing to do
with like fantasy a [ __ ] but this is a
short I like short series a lot I don't
like extended stuff which is why Full
Metal Alchemist is great watch erased
one of my top three favorite short
series ever did you watch Cowboy Bebop
I like cowboy be money - it was great
that's also classic erased is one of
those things that I [ __ ] love what is
so good one of my favorite movies is
Princess Mononoke Oh from Studio Ghibli
oh my god not an occasion gory it's a
little bit gory but oh my god it's
amazing
dude that's beautiful that [ __ ] was all
dry my hand yeah amazing yeah people
don't understand people [ __ ] [ __ ] on
2d animation and it's a dying art right
now because everybody likes 3d 2d is an
art form that's amazing there's
something that it captures that a lot of
people that you can't capture in 3d I
don't know what it is without 2d
animation there will be no 3d animation
yeah I think it's [ __ ] amazing man to
support your 2d [ __ ] animation out
there because once that art form dies
I'm gonna die I need someone to die man
yeah
I love that [ __ ] alright y'all that was
this episode of genius brain podcast
remember you can see us on iTunes
Spotify cast box all these different
audio platforms if you're watching this
on the youtubes and the videos you'll
give us the thumbs up and then leave in
the comments below about the stuff that
you want to see and like man Thank You
Julia for coming in I [ __ ] any time did
you come on every [ __ ] time oh hi Joe